[Music]
every damn day today is the very special
day we're gonna be playing will it stack
Pop Tart edition what's gonna be
happening here is we're gonna be
stacking Pop Tarts
so today Hannah's gonna be stacking hot
pop-tarts Natacha cold pop-tarts and
Jorden pop-tarts in the package Chris
has a chef's hat on he's gonna be
microwaving the pop-tarts which is very
dangerous don't do it in the foil as I
learned earlier it takes three seconds
to microwave a pop-tart
you guys want to explain now why you
chose which kind of pop-tart you chose
to set I chose hot pop-tarts because I
think this is a terrible idea so I'm
just gonna be eating them the entire
time great thanks for your enthusiasm
I chose cold pop-tarts because I'm a
cold-hearted woman very accurate Thank
You Jordan
why are you stacking packaged pop-tart
because I wasn't here on Friday when
they decided this is what's gonna happen
we're gonna put four minutes on the
clock the winner who has the most
stacked at the end of four minutes gets
20 seconds to brag to the camera and I'm
gonna be asking questions the whole time
when I ask these questions you have to
pause if you have to once you answer the
question you can resume stacking your
pop-tarts contestants are you ready yeah
all right folks here we go four minutes
on the clock
well it's that
what happening so I just start stacking
natasha's began eating hers and Jordan
is actually stacking warm ones do the
winner gets free snack any further spell
your middle name and i KH a why lov and
a mikhaylovna third grade teacher
Jennifer you're not even paying the
rules you're just acting anyway you
walked in it said Jennifer teach me math
oh it's kind of ok well that's apparent
Natasha
marry kill Woody Buzz Lightyear or mr.
Potato Head was Lightyear he's the most
ripped woody I think has the best brain
and emotional intelligence and yeah mr.
Potato Head you can kill him because he
dies all the time
ok great yeah keep stacking Jordan how
you doing there that's Chris it's gonna
fall I think the boy well you're gonna
hand off cuz you have to answer this
question Jordan what's 7 times 9 7 times
9 you know 61 363 keep stacking what are
the rules it has to be like you're the
rules are stacked the pop charts and
they were just eating things Chris yeah
hold on a second do you like my
questions yeah okay
would you rather feet for hands or hands
for feet hands her feet I can hang off
upside down more strawberry please
[Laughter]
Jordan this is interesting you've got
kind of like a double pile thing going
yeah I think there's like when Jordan
you guys decided when I was away like
taking my day off that I would get foil
mm-hmm like it's a slippery over in that
way okay before you do that would you
rather sleep standing up or eat a bunch
of nails sleep signing up I do that okay
sure yeah you can keep going no one
seems to be yeah Natacha keep going you
got more you can do this we're also
changing the rules it's about how high
you can stack it I don't care the number
I'm Jordan i won
what you just you haven't asked a
question oh wait who Ana before you
stack that I need to know something
would you would you rather look a shoe
yes like a shoe I'll be super mad right
now
guys we have 5 seconds left 5 4 3 1 2 do
these count as 2 or 1 1 ok 0 why the
count is 1 what are you talking about I
think Natasha is the winner the Tosh is
the winner everybody that's not true now
Jordan won you want to brag into the
camera go for it 20 seconds on the clock
Jordan you get to brag here's your
moment for those of you who like maybe
aren't like the most popular artwork so
like when you take your day off and
people decide oh let's just have a fun
day and like not really work we'll go to
lunch we'll go out to a bar what and I
said hi to her I mean just believe in
yourself that's well it's tak here's
something different right now epiphany a
moment when you suddenly become
conscious of something that is very
important
pooping in the star next to your manager
really evens the plan
that was an epiphany in history take a
little bit
there's just eaten a bee don't take the
eatin ones no that actually did balance
it that one balanced it the more you add
the better the bell yeah that's right
that's probably right okay as soon as I
let go it's over no no no you gotta calm
down
Jordan you gotta calm down we got it
looks like llamas bred from the Lord of
the Rings from missing what we're doing
at the bed I'm gonna throw this one how
many did we get I don't know just nobody
tell Nate that we did this
[Music]